[Music]
hello everyone Perry back again with
another exclusive Collider interview at
TIFF 2019 I'm very excited about this
one it is the team behind guns akimbo
I'm so excited for all of you but as I
was saying before we even started I am a
huge deaf chasm fan and it's been a
little too long since that movie came
out and I've just been eagerly awaiting
your next project so what was that time
span between movies like was it about
finding that important detail that got
you the green light working with Dawn's
best you know doing odds you know on the
streets no I mean that's crazy because
it actually doesn't feel like that long
for me because the the gestation period
for guns akimbo has been I mean after so
after the disk isn't or I pitched guns
akimbo these guys like I had a two-page
by outline or something and I like I've
got a script I'm like why not
and then I doubt a first draft in two
weeks so pretty much as soon as death
hasn't wrapped up I've been loosely
working on this as well as some other
patching for like dozens of other
projects and and wracking other things
but yeah so yeah I guess it gives it has
been quite a while and I'm saying you
know there's those directors that
mentioned you like two movies a year or
something how does that work like that's
insane I don't think that like most
people do you know like how long I say
you can make a film like from because
actually like the the obviously shooting
time it's generally very very short but
like most of the time like kill your
darlings I did the director have been
trying to get that going for seven years
like that and that's not even like that
long like you know it takes time yeah it
really does so when you're putting
together a script like this this is a
super ambitious second feature so are
you kind of red flagging concerns like I
want to put that in the script now but
someone might be worried about that
later when we're getting financing no I
mean I just I didn't really self censor
myself in that respect and and yeah
there was a lot of stuff that did have
to get lost just because of I wouldn't
have enough time to do it all like the
next coked in Mexico was well it was
originally in Amol so so that would have
been a whole different thing
were flight carps not chosen just
killing more people but uh we we flags
pretty soon that was extremely
problematic and so we had a killing like
a coke people you know you know working
a coke Factory because you know they're
expendable about human beings that they
can die so many people but at the same
time there was this there was this whole
other thing about a left and like and
there was a whole other floor of people
getting killed and and then the final
scene actually happens on a rooftop and
she like runs away and he's like bullets
whizzing past and she's slow-mo flips
and falls on this car and it all got
sort of truncated into what it was which
which you know felt like still more than
enough was a cool flip remember like
this all the splits she did the splits
and like shoots two guys in the deck at
the same time we probably had enough
dick stuff there are so many badass
frames of just the two of you I like I
know it's probably super vain but if I
were one of you I would freeze-frame
something and just blow it up because it
looks incredible yeah part of the fun is
like just getting to look I mean yeah
miles isn't good at it that's what's
great that's why I kind of could believe
myself in this role was the like he's a
very reluctant action person way he
doesn't really you know he wants to run
away running away is the main instinct
in the only kind of gets to fight really
and I think I look I I get some
reflected cool off just like being on
screen with Samar and her character
because her character is about Alston
think double she it's so amazing it made
me look really really cool yes you do
and also just like your experience doing
this over and over we were talking a
little while back it's like you have
great range but you definitely carved
out a part in the industry for yourself
just being like a badass leading lady on
screen and I'm loving it I wanted to ask
you guys what the biggest difference was
between your first impression of the
story after
the script for the first time and then
the final product cuz there is so
there's so many visual elements that
just go into the style and the tone and
everything did you get exactly what
Jason was going for right from the start
a lot of it like there was really great
descriptions in the in the script of
like you know you yeah I can't relate
though that a bullet you like you the
camera is like the point of view of a
bullet going in someone's head and then
like ricocheting out again and like that
was a you know there's the there was a
bunch of very very cool lake yeah there
was remember the mobile phone camera
thing we did there was a thing that was
awesome that Lake so I have a sensor I
basically had wealth a like a mic
strapped to my chest which had one of
our camera operators phones inside it
and that phone obviously has a gyroscope
in it which was then synced to the
camera so that when I roll the camera
rolls in its cage in exactly the same
way and so that's why some of the lows
like disorienting shots and I was just
like this so that was my main thing was
like looking through the script I was
like this is awesome
can we do this because I was like he's
written like car chases and explosions
on every page and so it was more a case
of like some what I was delighted by was
like from reading the script then being
on set was like how practical a lot of
it was and how like we were able to
really have Samara sitting on a
motorbike which was it and sitting
through the windscreen of the car with
my face next to the wheel like a lot of
that was there for real and that was
awesome incredible speaking of that kind
of technology is there anything else
that really came in handy to make you
just excel with your visuals any kind of
piece of tech in there that we don't
really know about or hear much about no
I mean I think the the AI rigged the
damn was talking about was something
very new for me like and yeah let us
some spin the camera a lot and do some
to some really cool things and other
than that I mean I'd never done anything
with a Russian arm like I'd nibbled any
car-chase stuff so there was there was
new for me and especially on the the
really rainy nights I got to sit in the
warm Russian arm carry everyone else's
out in the rain and I got out of the car
and like water was up to here I was like
why did I get out the car
but no that mean that there was it was
great like I got really thrust into that
cuz the car chase was like the second
day of the shoot and so I hadn't been
the director's chair for a few years and
then it's like okay second a car chase
but yeah I mean it all it all helps you
know hopefully they've got some more
tools in my belt for next time yeah some
like you know the high-tech stuff is
really cool but sometimes what's more
impressive on set is actually how good
the low-tech stuff then is like a lot of
the stuff on this was like there were a
few the running camera rigs for some of
the chase sequences that were literally
like ollie the grip had made this like
harness which was strapped to like two
pieces of scaffolding which had a camera
on the end which I could just like be
attached to me basically so I get but it
wasn't there's nothing like there's no
crazy technology in there it's just like
grips being really clever and like
strapping cameras to stuff was there any
kind of almost like a happy accident or
something that went completely wrong but
something even better than you
originally anticipated came out of it
man it must have been the muscles I mean
I'm trying to think like and there
always is yeah oh yeah yeah that was
great yeah with my rental car which I
thought really worked I think it cuz
like yeah we might have they caught just
shot and you were just because you like
sort of dodged on that car yes that
there was something I asked us something
to do dis on the day I'm like could you
just get mark
denne stunt double just can he just like
roll around on the car and they just
like look to me look at each other yeah
and I mean that they they would have
been fooling their rights to say [ __ ]
off you this is dangerous
to not do this and now they just the
only problem was no one wanted to use
their car and I had a rental in my okay
he was my rental he did like a rehearsal
and like you know Mac Mac's not a big
guy am I am i he'll be fine
dented the hell out of the car like
scratched all up on my our share we were
rolling now
so it waits do another one cause it
already damaged it and and then yeah
then we would you know fortunately it
was some of the producers account and I
wasn't responsible so
and but there was some great suitors
like a little bit like I mean I remember
like originally Danes character was a
skinhead and he was like I use my last
bullet on kept in white power there and
then it would chain them to do like a
more of a punk and that line doesn't
work and I think Sam you were like what
about cig [ __ ] Sudeikis I feel like
but I also feel that is like weirdly the
experience almost every day on set is
like you planning you plan you plan and
then you get there and like something
else will happen alongside it and that's
where it that's when it's really fun
like you're always like yeah you just
like discovering something every day I
mean like yeah Rhys Rhys Darby's like
improvisation of like the Cypress Hill
line which wasn't you know scripted and
now became like a very big part of our
soundtrack as well like there's stuff
like that which I feel like and that's
what's great about you as well as you
like you know you are open to that stuff
happening on set and like a lot of
directors can sort of be freaked out by
stop changing whereas Jason is like very
much like embraces everybody's eyes yes
that's very you're very egoless about I
mean I think it's good to be Florida and
and getting you know you you choose the
right people but also like you know you
have to trust in them to take it like
you know as a writer you can only write
a character like so far I reckon there's
my my sort of theory personally and then
when when an actor takes on that
character they give it a life of its own
and take it places that you would never
imagine and because and it's that's
great and they enhances the film and
yeah you have to sort of lose ownership
of it a little bit and yeah it's nice to
hear that you're so fluid about it
because when I watch a movie like this
not knowing what goes on behind the
scenes I just see such a specific style
and I imagine you have to plan
everything to achieve I'd be afraid
there would be no man there's definitely
some intricate planning especially
around the stunt stuff in the cast stuff
it's all you know very storyboards but
at the same time things go wrong you
have to adapt like we had our L mixes
car a brake broke down almost every time
we're gonna add one car and like it was
all this all the stuff there at any
moment it could have gone wrong but we
improvised and I think that that's the
cool thing about working with and we
talk about the cocaine the other day
like snorting the cocaine and then I I
thought I'd have a go like when she's
stalling coke off the O's e vitamin C
yeah yeah the good stuff for the parties
but like yeah and I thought I could ever
go at doing it and I start tried
smelling it and it made me almost puke
and died in front of the whole crew who
mocks me relentlessly and then someone
like pointed out that no nostril was
seen in the Sharks you can just get at
the top of the top of the dollar bill or
whatever and then that's just as good
and yeah yeah you really had to put its
vitamin C powder so you're healthier
you're int so that's how I keep from
getting myself not gonna start doing
that site it did remind me of what would
you rather question for you know fret
would you rather have to fake sneeze or
fig vomit in the scene they go mad
understand at a time really makes these
things hard
I don't like face an easing is a really
hard thing to do thank you do you do a
little one I thought you didn't I
thought I heard you doing yeah lovely
soup yeah it was just like a vegetable
soup or something and it's and it and I
feel like vomiting is something I was
gonna say about my eating something I've
done more than sneezing which is
definitely not true but but yeah I feel
like that's an easier thing to act
certainly would you rather have enough
time and not enough money or enough
money and not enough time there's a time
I think cuz woohoo comes down to time
like a it so just like that that's the
thing about film shoots there is an
apparent everyone is it's like basically
a ticking clock and you know the light
you losing lies and all the stuff so
yeah definitely definitely time I think
money money is important but yeah you
can overcome that yeah you can overcome
it but I also think that like the
reality is that that if you that you
will not have both things at the same
time you will not have enough money and
so you will not have enough time whereas
I think the first thing money gets you
is more time generally so it's a weird
yeah but so when you're on this
situation yeah we just we just in most
films like you know since even poorer
you just like you do we don't have a
nothing like that but like it always
gets a I've also like an interesting
because like I'm part of we also
obviously had all the money in the world
and all the time in the world but
actually like doesn't you know those
storms are amazing and I love doing them
but they're actually it isn't as much of
a necessary as an advantage as I think
some I often talk to directors and I'm
just like actually you have to be so
much more decisive because you haven't
got the luxury of time I think the
luxury of time money just buys you the
luxury of not having to make a choice
right now and so often the period of
like deciding stuff gets like oh we'll
work it out later and actually I think
when you have less of that you are just
much more focus because you have to be
it's the great creative juices flowing
in a different kind of way to and
there's like a real sort of urgency yeah
this question came up in another
interview that I did and I was surprised
I hadn't thought about this too much
that when you're part of an ensemble you
get to observe other actors work all the
time but as a director you don't really
get that opportunity so if you could be
a fly on the wall on another directors
film what director would you choose oh
yeah that's a good question sorry
currently working or not or just like a
lot of you did pick any one you want
[Music]
really I mean I think you brick just
because I hear so many mad stories about
about behind the scenes and you hear
about I'm doing like a hundred takes of
someone picking up a fork or something
and I'm like firstly I want to know how
does he manage to convince his producers
to give him like a hundred takes and
like this like folk picking up like
without without getting into a fistfight
because I do like three
eggs and I've got them like literally
like grabbing my shoulders but um yeah
also also like you know I mean obviously
a genius but um yeah like II I just love
to see the way he worked and the other
way as mind operatives
I had a story once about him I don't
know like if this is comparable or true
that he like had worked a six he'd
worked six days in a week and he wanted
to work the seventh day and was told by
his a DS it was like you can't we all
need a day off you have to give everyone
a day off
and so he apparently got in like an
entirely new crew for the seventh day
and then just resumed with the other
crew on Monday again I don't know if
that's true but I was told that by an
old lady in England which is my version
of gospel truth yeah I can't imagine
that even being worth it to kind of
regain your putting in that Mary yes is
the no I've gone out his own mile I
don't want to stop making this film I
guess he was such a genius at that point
and so respected that he could ya like
actually make those demands yeah I'm
always like fascinated by that like when
you hear about actors who have like
crazy demands I always want to know like
what was the first film you did where
you were like I can get crazy now I can
start asking for some truly crazy stuff
yeah I got the rap upside and I did want
to end on this question just because I
think that you know this is an extreme
stylized situation but we're in a world
where we have our heads buried in our
phone and we have reality TV and
competitions like that like in our face
24/7 so just for fun if you could be in
a reality TV show yourself what would
you choose and why does does this assume
that I have the skills to get into
whatever reality TV show I want or do I
have my courage my choice is chopped
Brian a [ __ ] okay so that's what
everyone going I'm going I'm going with
with yeah with chopped til MasterChef or
cutthroat kitchen good you're not
terrible so one day well-known chef
edition of Joe I can't do it but I'd
love to be on RuPaul's Drag Race
I was trying to pitch my own TV show
called tethered and it's like what you
do is you get like sorry like
two completely different people like
some outright racist and black lives
matters person tether them together for
a week something awful totally awful
either that or monkey chains for islands
get some monkeys in on our island chain
saw and you just said are you serious I
think he no no he's just pinched anger
show monkey chainsaw I love maybe maybe
in Japan somewhere there was um ya know
I I feel like you might also it is like
pick your next movie or the sequel to
this yeah I just my tailor like [ __ ]
together and just see what happens it
makes a good spiritual sequel to us yeah
alright I hope to say goodbye but thank
you guys so much for your time today and
I want to let everybody out there no
guns akimbo do keep an eye out for and
if you haven't seen it yeah go check out
death chasm while you wait for it do not
leave this video without liking and
sharing it and stay tuned we're gonna
have more tip 20:19 coverage coming your
way real soon